parents should pay attention to that and
get their kids off of it you're not
ready for that when you're a teenager
Megan Fox is a not a fan of social media
so much so that she plans on keeping her
kids away from technology for as long as
possible do you make that choice to kind
of give your kids that I'm just normal
life as possible my kids in particular
I'm enrolling them in a school where you
know technology is not allowed until
they're much older and then they're
introduced to computers and things like
that because they will need that
eventually into function in the real
world but as children they shouldn't be
around it at all in my opinion and so my
kids won't have cell phones or tablets
or or any of that it interferes with a
brain development I'm really big into
this I'm very passionate about it Megan
opened up to et about her boys at
WonderCon she was there to promote
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles out of the
shadows one question you guys like a
thing more family-friendly this time
definitely more family-friendly like we
went in and we wrote stuff to make sure
that six-year-olds can understand the
dialogue so it's definitely more family
being a mom is that important to you to
produce content that your kids can see
it would be nice to make some things
that they can see yeah because you know
something like Jennifer's body I'm not
gonna let them see for a long time
something like Jonah Hex I'm not going
see ever no one should ever see that
movie
so yeah it's nice I didn't pick this
going I need to make a family film but I
picked it with them in mind yeah do your
kids understand what that mommy and
daddy are famous no I mean the oldest
one is only three he has no concept of
he tries to understand that I'm in a
movie but at that age they still think
movies are real so he doesn't understand
like the crossover between pretendin
and real life